foreign
that you're a cloud engineer and you
have to provision a virtual machine for
your Dev environment install and
configure the dependencies and then
decide to create an identical virtual
machine for your test environment are
you confident that you can recreate the
same configuration sure
what about all the tweaks you made to
run things in the dev environment did
you track them maybe
can you verify that the two environments
are configured identically once they are
provisioned no not really what happens
when you need to scale this same
configuration to thousands of machines
to support production usually that means
a lot of late nights in this video learn
how you can overcome these challenges
using terraform and ic2 hello my name is
Rekha and I'm on we're technical
curriculum developers here at Google
Cloud
here's what's covered in this video
common provisioning pain points IAC and
its benefits an introduction to
terraform terraform's features and the
terraform workflow
gone are the days where assistant
administrator had to manually configure
hundreds of servers networks and
firewall rules to UI with the rapid
scaling of it infrastructure devops
teams are struggling to efficiently
manage the growing business needs they
need technology that can scale rapidly
eliminate operational bottlenecks close
communication loops and most importantly
reduce the frequency of human errors
here is where IAC can help IEC what's
IAC infrastructure as code or IAC is
managing and provisioning infrastructure
through configuration language instead
of a UI it is the foundational concept
of terraform what about support for
Google Cloud the good news is Google
Cloud is already tightly integrated with
their form like I mentioned any
technology that can scale rapidly better
yet at
the help you handle massive growth and
demand for your implications I'm
wondering whether you can use IAC to
configure different types of
infrastructure elements give me a few
examples okay let's start at the bottom
I need a VPC with subnets and custom
firewall rules yes I have virtual
machines and bare metal systems of
course yes I've containers deployed to
kubernetes clusters why not as we scale
we're going to use a combination of
these done the important thing about IAC
is that it helps you capture the process
in a way that can be
and automated if IAC can help me with
all of these pain points what's
terraform all about IEC is a concept
whereas terraform is the IEC tool
a definition that
tensors infrastructure as code tool
created by hashicot that lets you
provision Google Cloud Resources with
declarative configuration files examples
of resources include virtual machines
containers storage Network and a lot
more terraform allows infrastructure to
be expressed as code in a simple human
readable language called HCL sounds
interesting but I'm looking for support
for an Enterprise level infrastructure
terraform has an open source structure
with three different editions that range
from self-hosted to fully managed
including Enterprise support great I'm
curious to learn more do I have to code
everything from scratch not really
terraform also has a large community
including a registry with fully
available modules for Google cloud
deployments and reusable modules for
standardized resource deployments
okay let's use a real world example and
see how terraform works for example in a
common two-tier architecture you would
have a pool web servers that use a
database tier how can terraform help let
me answer that question by using the IEC
workflow which includes five different
phases okay let's go you start with a
scope page where you Scope the
requirements for the Google Cloud
resources and plan how they should be
connected in this case scope the type of
compute and database instances needed
okay I can do that the terraform
workflow begins with the author phase
where you author the configuration code
for the infrastructure you want to
create referring to your example during
this phase you code the configuration of
the instance the VPC Network and the
database instance that you require okay
remind me what language is used to write
this configuration that would be HCL
and how does terraform know that I'm
using Google Cloud great question we do
that in the next phase the initialize
space where plugins or modules are
installed during this phase you run the
terraform init command which initializes
the terraform configuration directory
and installs Google Cloud as the
provider okay that makes sense what's
next next is the plan phase you run the
terraform plan command this command
helps you review The Plan before
applying it to your Google Cloud
infrastructure and then am I finished is
my infrastructure Creator not yet the
terraform plan is like the rehearsal
before the actual show after you review
the configuration described in the plan
you apply it to create the actual
infrastructure resources that all sounds
amazing I can't wait to get started
using this how and where can I install
terraform and how can I learn HCL these
are all excellent questions which are
answered in our beginner friendly course
getting started with their form for
Google Cloud click the link in the
description box below to enroll in this
training see you there
[Music]